this is a production of cornell
university
yeah um good afternoon to everyone um
thank you for your interest in this
session
so yes i'm diana obregon i'm a phd
student in entomology department at
cornell and today i want to show you um
the results of an experiment that we did
in in 2019
um trying to understand how different
thyme toxin applications in squash crops
can impact pest control but at the same
time
pollinators
so we know that growers that cultivate
crops are highly dependent on on
pollinators such as apple or passion
fruits or blueberries they are facing a
constant dilemma because they need to
find best practices to control the
the pests in the crop but at the same
time they need to protect pollinators in
order to get the maximum jilt so they
are facing all the
all the time this this they are looking
all the time for these new practices
that can help them
and this is the case for cucurbits for
squash for pumpkins for watermelons
because these crops are entirely
dependent on animal pollination to
produce fruits and this is because they
have separate female and male flowers
and the pollen is very heavy and sticky
so they really require the work of peace
to
do the pollination in order to produce
fruits
and in this region the main pollinators
are the squash peas the bumblebees and
the honeybees and in particular i want
to highlight the squash the squash beets
because these are specialist beast they
feed only on cooker beets and they
nest in the ground
between the the the crop field so
anything that we do
in the crop might impact this space
um and i wanted to show you just how the
nest entrance looks like so you can see
the
the holes that they made and all the
soil around and if we have the
opportunity to look at the profile of
the nest you can see that there's they
build a tunnel with different um
cavities where they storage the pollen
that they collected from the crop and
then they lay eggs and the larvae will
fit from the uh from the pollen
and from our data in that experiment we
reinforced the idea that these are
important for these crops so you can see
in the in this graph that as the number
of b visits increase there's an increase
in fruit number but also an increase in
fruit weight so really these bees are
contributing to
the crop production of these um species
but on the other hand we know that we
have pests too so the main test in this
system is the stripe cucumber beetle um
and we know also from like previous
studies and from our study that um when
there's an increased defoliation caused
by this beetle there's a decrease in
fruit number per plant
so these
pests
can really
diminish the yield but also we know that
they can be vector of bacterial
pathogens
so what growers commonly do is that they
apply neonicotinoids at the beginning of
the crop as a prophylactic measure and
then they usually spray like
two or three times more with peritoids
but neonicotinoids in particular there
has been a lot of attention because of
their effect on bees we know that these
are systemic insecticides and in
cucurbits the main molecule that is
applied is thiameth
yeah
oh
i thought you were calling me so the
main molecule that growers apply in this
system is thiamine toxin
and this
molecule has been registered for
informal soil treatments and foliar
sprays for several years
and since 2009 has been also registered
as the insecticidal component of seed
treatments
by the name of cruiser
and but we know that because these
molecules are systematic they can move
throughout the tissues of the plant and
they can move like for example from the
roots to the flowers or from the leaves
to the flowers uh even reaching the
pollen and the nectar so the bees can be
exposed to them and this is unfortunate
because these molecules are highly toxic
for the bees
so in our experiment we wanted to test
how this different prophylactic
application of thyme toxin
impact pest control b visitation jill
and the pesticide residues in the
flowers
and our goal was to try to find if any
of those different application methods
can provide a good level of pest control
but at the same time reduce the
pesticide risk for the bees
and for that we use these three products
um so we use platinum
by syngenta that is designed to be used
as any forward treatment actara as a
foliar spray and cruiser as a seed
treatment
and you can see already like like the
diff the the different treatments
provide different amounts of active
ingredients so for example for infero
you get um at the end like doing all the
calculations
um you get like
0.028 grams per plant
and in comparison to foliar spray that
you get half of it and for seed
treatment is it's um
much less than that
and
for our experiment we also wanted to
test two different plant varieties to
have different
pest pressure scenarios so we use golden
zucchini that is a variety that is
highly preferred by the beetle and we
also use success pm that is a variety
that is less prepared by the beetle
based on previous studies
so this is how
our experiment looked like in the field
so we did it in treeville new york and
we
had these four treatments including a
control with no insecticides the two
varieties and for each combination we
have seven replicas for a total of
56 plots
and every plot contains 24 plants that
and you can see the the distribution
more or less that we had
um and
we measure in every plot we measure the
percentage of defoliation that was
caused by the triple convert beetle the
visitation of the bees
the number of fruits the fruit weighed
and also during the flowering we
collected samples of nectar and pollen
at two time points so at the beginning
of the flowering in early june and then
two months later in august to have two
um
moments and to see if like the pesticide
um decrease with time so pesticide
residues
and to know if the pesticides that we
found in the flowers can
represent hazard for the least we
measured these
we use this calculation called the
hazard quotient and basically it's a
relation between the mean concentrations
of the residues that we found in nectar
and pollen multiplied by the exposure so
how much nectar or pollen the bees
consumes or get into contact with it
um
and this divided by the oral or contact
ld50 um so ld50 the it's the lethal
doses at which 50 of the population that
you are like testing will die
so if we have if we do these
calculations and we get hazard questions
that are equal or above one
that indicates that the levels of
exposure to the pesticide can cause
50 or more percent of mortality and that
represents a little hazard for the b so
we are going to calculate this
um hazard question for squash piece that
we learned before that is the most
sensitive species in this system
okay so this is these are the results um
so first we look at the defoliation um
so you can see that we have in the
x-axis all the different pesticide
treatments
and in the y-axis the percentage of the
foliation caused by the striped
curcumverbator
the only
differences was
the in forward treatment in relation to
the the to the other so infertile had
the least defoliation in comparison to
seed treatments further spread and no
insecticides and as you see it's
surprising that the other two
insecticide treatments were not
different from the control treatment
for the plum varieties as expected we
found that golden zucchini had more
defoliation than success pm
and when we we expected that before
now for the yield so in the left we have
the fruit number
and we can see again that infero is a
treatment that is is is different so it
it had it produced more fruit numbers
than the other treatments and there was
no difference between seed treatment
foliar sprayed or no insecticide
and we found basically the same for um
for the fruit weight so
in furrow had the highest red weight in
comparison to the rest and foliar spray
was even lower than the control than the
new insecticides
in relation to the b visits we
um we thought that the treatments with
the highest number of b visits were the
the citrine and the infrared treatment
and in particular
for the success pm
variety and this was because they um
because they they had less defoliation
they also had more flowers so that uh
that um resulted in more visited
more visits per plot
and these are the residues the thyme
toxin residues that we found in the
flower so this there's a lot in this
table but in the top you can see the
four treatments early means that results
from the early flowering so in early
june and then late and that was in
august and then you can see the results
for nectar and pollen and then the
frequency of quantification that's the
num the percentage of samples that we
found with some level of pesticides and
then the range that's the concentration
of the pesticide that we found
um and as you see
um
for the forward treatment it's actually
again the treatment that is very
different so you see that there's um the
higher frequencies and also
higher concentration of the pesticides
we also measure um clothing
that is the main
metabolite of thiametoxin so that when
when thyme toxin is absorbed by the
plants it can degrade into clothianudine
so we need to also check this type of
molecules so in this case we found
residues of clothing just for this
treatment so again it's like
the treatment that was different from
the rest
and you can see here just the treatments
um and in the y-axis the concentration
and again
the highest concentration were was found
in forward treatment
but how little are those concentrations
right because we yeah we can see like it
ranges between like zero point something
to 40 something but how bad are they
so when we calculate the the hq that has
a question that we talked before
there was just one
um condition where the levels were above
one
um
so that means that for that condition
the there's a little risk for the piece
so in this case you can see i
highlighted with a red line um the
condition is when you're using forward
treatments
um
and you sample flowers at the beginning
of the flowering season
at that moment this treatment represents
a little hazard first squash piece in
particular
and this is pretty similar to what was
found in ontario canada by susan chen
she did an experiment in hoop houses
where she
had bees
nesting in different treatments and you
can see in the right different
treatments that she tested and she found
that the
number of nests that these the squash
pits could establish in these hoop
houses was uh were dramatically reduced
when there was application of emilio
clubrid to the soil so this is a similar
neonicotinoid
compared to thymotoxin but we can see
that for seed treatment was not that bad
or for foliar sprayed with these
insecticides um
so like these applications to the soil
are very bad for the bees
so in summary what we found we found
that informal applications um
resulted in the less defoliation in the
highest fruit number and the highest
fruit weight
but also at the same time it resulted in
the highest pesticide residues with the
potential to be a lethal hazard for
squash feeds
in particular in the early flowery
and surprisingly we did not find
difference between the seed treatment
and the foliar sprays in comparison to
the control which is worrying because we
know that the c treatments are the most
common um
use the most common application method
um
and in relation to the variety we found
that being had the least affiliation so
this it's it's uninteresting to see that
there's a um a variety that
it's less susceptible to the strikeful
convert bureau but unfortunately we
didn't see
um differences in geo significant
differences in jail
so what is our study saying or showing
is actually that the commercial
applications that we use currently of
cyanotoxin
they don't really provide a sustainable
solution for squash growers because in
one for one hand and furrow was really
good to control the pest to produce a
good yield but it's also at risk for the
bees
in the short and the long term
and in the other side seed treatments
were not as good as we expected
um
so but what can we do in the meantime we
really need to keep
looking for solutions right that growers
can implement in their field but in the
meantime we suggest that we
that growers need to avoid any continued
use or limited to suit treatments
they should implement and use best dress
holes
if they need to apply um they could try
to apply after the flowers have closed
so this is
usually for squash crops in the in the
afternoon
um we also suggest that they should
avoid tan mixing of insecticides and
fungicides because that increased
toxicity and i'm sure maria will
expand on this information
um and also for a specific if
specifically for cooker beets you should
avoid to do pesticide applications over
the nesting aggregations so when we saw
the nest they they usually aggregated so
you should avoid to like destroy or
contaminate their nest
and
something that you can also do is leave
a margin of bare ground to ensure that
there's some space for the squash and
ground nesting bees
and with that i want to thank you
everyone uh the sponsor so this this
work was funded by usda and um i am
funded with a fulbright scholarship from
colombia
and
i'm glad to like
here or any questions or comments ask
dan has a question here could you show
the slide that has the table of hq
values you found
and you're going back to that
do you have a particular question about
that then
yeah in this one when you show the hq is
only a
above one for female contact oral
in the nectar is that correct
it's it's um only above one
for when you have what from when you did
in forward treatments but
just for the samples of flowers that we
took at the beginning of the flowering
season
so like the first week of june we
collected these flowers and we found
levels that are
lethal for squash peas and the
calculation is done for
the whole life cycle so we take into
account the amount of the pollen that
the larva
eats the amount of pollen that the adult
are in contact with or also the amount
of vectors that they can ingest and this
is based on previous studies of the
species of the of these these species
okay and were you seeing a
difference in i thought on the riverside
show that the bees were still coming to
the flowers later in the season is that
correct or no even with you yeah they're
coming all the time they actually
prefer
plants that are
that were treated with informal or seed
treatment just because they have more
flowers and they are like they have less
defoliation so bees are actually
attracted to these healthier plants that
were treated with the highest
concentration of the pesticide
i guess my last question i'm just kind
of wondering the hazard quotient is
above one but the
the flowers are still being visited and
the yield is still being increased
yes so the thing is that
it's not you know the bees
will go to the flowers they feel
attracted to those like beautiful
big flowers and they will collect the
this
nectar and pollen that is contaminated
and can be lethal for them but they
won't die in the flower they will die
somewhere else in the nest or somewhere
else so the the actual declining in the
population we will see it through time
so if we have the opportunity to like
measure a field that is treated within
forum
um applications through time we will see
a declining beast but we won't see that
right away
okay thank you
okay all right hi there i am glad to be
here presenting pesticide risk to bees
today um
i'll be discussing what we know and what
we need to know better and i want and i
wanted to start this out by showing you
where
exposure
really really occurs for bees and it's
on the pollen
um and so i want to show you
various bee species and how they their
babies survive
so right here we have an egg that hasn't
hatched but as soon as it hashes it'll
gobble up all that pollen
um adult bees eat very little pollen
they mostly collect it for their young
so this is a osmia we have a mega kylie
here
in nest and leaves
we have
the the squash bee that deanna was just
talking about and then um
this is a khalidis and so they all eat
it very they you know they prep their
meal very differently and then here in
the middle what i'm going to be talking
about the most is the honeybee and they
feed you know daily they feed their
larva um their their pollen bread
so i just wanted you to keep that in
mind as i go through this talk
um and let's see i can't change the
slide
ah here okay so since 2006 we've seen 40
to 68
of
um colony b loss per year and this and
um
this last year we lost out of a hundred
thousand hives that we have here in new
york we lost
56 thousand so that's 56 percent of our
hives we're losing
and at the same time
um
we know that we have also seen a decline
in our native bee populations
so from previous and current research we
know that at least 53 of those native
bee species are experiencing some form
of range contraction
or
population declines and in a couple
cases we haven't seen these bees in
about 10 to 15 years
so
why is this happening
well there are multitude of factors
presented here
i'm going to focus on
pesticides
um because this is i i would like to
focus on this because this is the one
factor that we have some kind of control
over
either with our voting power or our
research power and our education power
so um
i'm going to talk to you about what we
know about pesticides and the impacts
they're having on bees
so here's a little
um map of where i'll go in this talk um
first we're going to talk about what uh
about defining pesticide risk so what do
scientists and regulators mean when they
talk about risk and
um diana really went over this quite
well but i will just refresh you in
reference to where we're going in this
talk
um
then you'll see some examples of where
uh where there is risk and whether it's
not risk
and then we'll move on to what we need
to know better um
and we know a little bit but what do we
need to know better so where is exposure
coming from and what's going on why are
we so focused on fungicides all of a
sudden
okay so for the um defining risk if i or
someone else
talk about risk what does that actually
mean
this is a simple means of understanding
it risk is two things it's exposure so
how much of something are you exposed to
and then toxicity how bad is that thing
for you if you ingest it or you contact
it
okay so
we typically use a metric called the
hazard quotient there's other metrics
but um
regulatory agencies researchers and
pesticide industry
typically use hazard quotient so here um
i'll
re review this quickly
um
but uh
diana really did get a good review of it
but we do it in a little different way
okay so
for a typical fungicide
um during pollination
we i'm showing you this example of the
bee getting exposed to a thousand parts
per billion of this fungicide
so that's how much fungicide the bees
are exposed to
and
um
and from other studies
we know that this fungicide
is
that if the bee comes into contact with
100 micrograms of this fungicide
at least 50 of the bees that come into
contact with this amount of
the chemical will die or
or more 50 or more so this is known
that's why this is known as the ld50 um
that's interchangeable with toxicity in
this case
so
if we co combine those two things we
have a hazard quotient of 10. while 0.1
of an ld50 is really low
um
if we could take that same amount that
the same measure this 1000 parts per
billion
and we can take a real a really toxic
chemical like imidacloprid
which has an ld50 of 0.004
and
with this if we do a thousand
uh parts per billion
we can end up with 250
000 250 000 hazard quotients so this is
2500 over the ld50
um so this is uh
the same amount of chemical but now you
have much more risk because that
chemical is so much more toxic
so this is an extreme right like rarely
do we see this in the landscape
what is really common to see in the
landscape is something more like 40
parts per billion of imidacloprid
so
you multiply that and we get 10 000 it
has a quotient of 10 000. okay so that's
a lot less than 250 000
but
um
but this is still like
this is
this 10 000 is 100 of an ld50 so
you know a population of these
uh getting exposed to 40 parts per
billion of emitted copper
they run the risk of
of about 50 of the that population
dying
okay so all of this is just to say what
is going on when we're measuring risk
combination of exposure and toxicity
so
that's what risk is
let's talk about now let's talk about
when there's risk and when there is not
risk
okay so
in the pesticide analysis lab um that
scott mccart um
helps run
they have randomly they this is based on
around 4 000 pollen samples that have
come through that lab and what they find
that
during day-to-day bee keeping um
those the pollen samples that are just
coming in throughout the year there's
barely any risk from pesticides
however once bees you know once the
spring starts and the bees start
visiting flowering crops
that risk starts to escalate extremely
so it's all happening during flowering
and not surprising because that's when
the bees are coming in contact with it
but just to point that out and um to for
an example of
this i'll show you um
a pro
a research project in new york apple
pollination with honeybees
this is 30 orchards that we've been on
and off visiting for the last decade
and the lab our researchers went out and
multiple times a week they sampled
pollen provisions from each orchard
and um then they took those palm
provisions and one by one put them
through the
pollen analysis
um
machine
and
they
they popped out a list of pesticides
here
so this is one so what i'm showing you
here is this sample from 2016 this is
one pollen
provision sample from orchard n
and this one sample had 17 pesticides
found in it of these 17 pesticides 10 of
them were fungicides
now that doesn't seem so bad like
fungicides how you know how bad could
they be for bees they're fungicide but
this over this talk you'll see like how
um
like what what this what the risk is
here truly
of the fungicides um
they also found three insecticides so
remember these pollen provisions were
taken during apple bloom so during apple
bloom apple growers don't spray these
insecticides so these are coming from
pre-bloom sprays or they're coming from
somewhere else right but they're still
they're still
um
contributing to the exposure
here
and then we also found some trace
amounts of herbicides
so
that one pollen sample came from this
orchard orchard in here and
um so you can see this
this orchard there was so there was
other provisions that were tested from
this orchard but this orchard showed to
be over exceeded the us epa acute
exposure
level of concern
so
meaning that and the epa sets this at 40
percent
okay so that so back in 2016 when we did
this it was like oh that's not so good
um
okay well that's just two farms
but you know
you know scott and david and nico
continued to do this for five more years
up until and
um
and up until 2021 and so i just pulled a
slide from 2019 a summary slide
and what we see what we typically see is
a lot of variation year to year and so i
pulled 2019 because this this year out
of those same
um orchards that had been tested this
whole time
we found nine of those orchards nine of
those 20 orchards
had
were above far exceeded the ep a level
of concern
so
some years it might be two farms some
years it might be 50 of the farms here
and in one of these farms it it was over
300 percent of the at the level of
concern
so
um
risk can change year to year
so what does this mean so um
our colleagues have found similar
similar results in michigan blueberry
new jersey blueberry and new york
strawberry and they also find
year-to-year variation and there's on
average
varies thirty to four that thirty to
forty percent of the orchards exceed epa
acute level of concern
so this begs the question why aren't
there requirements to assess real-world
exposure
after releasing a product
it's just something to think about here
okay so now what do we need to know
better
where is exposure coming from
so a colleague of ours kelsey graham did
um
similar work to our apple work in
michigan blueberry pollination
and she took pollen provision samples
from
honeybees
um across 20 different orchards i mean
20 different uh blueberry farms
and
analyzed the pollen for what they are
bringing back as far as pesticides and
so she split it up she looked at
unsprayed
farms organic farms and conventional
farms
and
what she found was
that
and
on average all of these farms brought
back around 35 pesticides
for in the pollen provisions and so it
was
this is really interesting because
unsprayed farms shouldn't be having any
pests they shouldn't be having anything
out
else
organics shouldn't they should have
other stuff in there and convention and
then we'd expect it on conventional
but she was seeing the same amounts no
matter what kind of farming farm
management and so where where are these
pesticides coming from
um you know it's definitely like off the
farm right
or it's in during from
non-uh spraying during non-bloom so
kelsey went out and they and she
with this she like
he investigated further she went and
interviewed all the growers asked them
for spray records looked at um what they
sprayed before bloom during bloom and
after bloom
and
what she found was that
almost 60 percent of the pesticides
found
in the pollen provisions were from
not uh from
were pesticides that are not registered
on blueberry at any time so these
weren't coming from blueberry anywhere
right
so that's pretty significant um she also
found that a small amount was from
um pesticides sprayed when blueberries
were not in bloom that's predictable
and then also because
that's predictable because some
pesticides linger in the soils and in
the tissues of the plants
um and then she also found that
some of the pesticides
were um not necessarily from that farm
but they were from a
they weren't sprayed on that farm but
they were sprayed on farms nearby and
that's not surprising because centipedes
like to travel
um and then as you would expect it like
the focal the
in conventional fields is where she
found that there were pesticides that
were actually sprayed in there
so um
where so yeah where were these
other pesticides and ones not registered
for blueberry coming from and
you know could it be these seats these
these uh field crops that have seed
treatments or like what diana talked
about were like you know um
squash you know they have seed treatment
as well so are these coming
from other crops um
is it or is it from the wildflowers on
the field along the field margins and
the trees
um
our
grad student studied a bunch of flowers
and trees and found that these are
visiting trees quite a bit
so
um the conclusion is that many exposures
come from outside focal farms
so what does that mean for regulations
you know how how do we deal with that
and
um also we found that several pesticides
are lingering from pre-bloom sprays
um do we need the pesticide
labels need to be changed or updated or
more transparent what do you do with
that information how do we utilize that
okay so now fungicides
um what's what why what's with all the
fungicide
um research these days
um
scott mccart when he was a postdoc he he
got this he did this study looking at
um it's not this slide here but he
looked at um bumble bee declines across
the u.s and they they looked at all
kinds of variables and what they found
was that the increase in
fungicide use correlated with the
decrease and the the
the bumble bee declines across bumblebee
species declines across the us and so he
had always wanted to like further ask
questions about this and then
um
dion diana de souza came and she was
really interested in further
exploring this question
and
with hers we start you know in the since
he had done that work these synergisms
had started to come in like synergisms
are when a
uh
the fungicide
combines with an insecticide and
basically
um makes
that insecticide exponentially more
toxic
and so
where so she was curious she's like is
the
you know
the effects of the fungicide is that
from direct toxicity toxicity or is it
these synergisms
so she they chose together um captain
because it was the third most used
fungicide any use in the u.s
and so she had four treatments control
captain alone diametoxin and then did
captain plus thiamethoxan to explore the
synergy
and to look at realistic levels of
exposure and kind of try to understand
that level of exposure component
she also broke that down into
different exposure levels and so they
picked 100 parts per billion because in
all the pollen samples that come through
that pump that pesticide analysis lab
almost all the samples from
apple show to have about a hundred parts
per billion of cap can in them
and then very often they also have 500
parts per billion so they chose
that for the medium because sometimes
they there wasn't 500 parts per billion
and then they chose the high
level of exposure for captain to be 2
000 because that's the highest level
they ever documented
and they did a similar thing for
thiamethoxam
so
um 10 parts per billion is low
and 70 parts per billion
is occurs but it's it's
it doesn't occur all the time and then
um 1400 parts per billion is the highest
level documented as well
and what she found was that captain
increased mortality by 80
this is a fungicide and here it's acting
more like a b aside you know
so we don't typically we don't typically
think of fungicides being
um like hurting the insect you know
hurting our
our
insects um so
this
was a interesting finding this was
specifically with larva and pupa
um
and if you look at this this one i just
added here so these
these mortality rates were similar and
not significantly different from the
mortality uh when um low amounts of thy
methoxima are applied
so
you know there again it's acting like an
insecticide
and then the the one piece of um good
news
was these last three bars down here this
was the combination exploring the
synergy and so this is captain plus
biomethoxin and we don't see
any synergistic um
any synergistic increase in mortality
from that so that's good that's not
happening out in the landscape and
that's that's good to know
um
but so she looked at captain and she
thought
you know but this is the same thing
going on in some of our other
other fungicides excuse me other
fungicides you know especially some of
these ones are classically known to be
synergistic like we keep blaming
synergies is there something else going
on
and so she looked at different
flexor pyroxide and fenbuconazole and
found similar increases
63
44 and 52 increase in mortality
and these were not that different from
um the
the bio assets that she did on
thiamethoxime and acetamiprid as well
there's similar mortality rates and when
you pool all this together so she pooled
low medium high low medium high for each
of these chemicals
she pulled that together
these
mortality rates were not significantly
different
so that is
really interesting and it's
and the more interest the most
interesting part is that all of these
fungicides
are
you know
it's a it's a surprise that they're
doing as much to bees
that we never knew about
so why are honeybee larvae so sensitive
to fungicides
um we are exploring this more we're
starting to do
scott's starting to do microbiome
research in our native bee lab brian
danforth is um driving some um research
on uh native b
um microbiome research so hopefully we
can present on that in the next few
years
um and also i wanted to let you know
that epa is starting to consider larval
assays during pesticide registration
registration but will larval assays be
given as much importance as adult assays
and
honestly it seems like they might they
probably need to be given a little bit
more since b adult bees aren't the ones
typically eating the pollen i mean they
eat a little bit
but you know larva are
eating the bulk of the pollen collected
so maybe these
these assays should be done specifically
on larva um
so
and in collaboration with dice and um
pmap
um
we published some pesticide decision
making guides to protect
pollinators um we'll be putting out some
in for small fruits and others for
vegetable this spring and summer
um
and this guide for apple i think it's a
misnomer that we called it a
decision-making guide it should be an
education guide
but they're really helpful in teaching
you what
um each of the chemicals has been
reported to do to
the
bees that has been these species that
they've been tested on
um
so i encourage any questions and want to
let you know that any of you
can send in pollen samples to our
pesticide analysis lab anybody anybody
in new york or vermont or anywhere can
it's 90 a sample
um if there's any questions this is the
end of my talk
maria thank you so much um
really fascinating and scary as well
yeah i know i don't know where yeah
we'll see where we
go with it and what happens and
um
maria i had a question
this is mary um oh hi
hi
so you were saying that one of the
things that you're thinking with
fungicides and why they might be
[Music]
uh so toxic for bees is the microbiome
but i guess i'm a little bit confused
about that because i think that the
ld50s that are created
in the lab are usually done with just
like a feeding assay that might not even
involve pollen and it looked like even
desos work
was it pollen or you know like a sucrose
solution
um it was
i believe it was
oh my gosh
i have to look at that again i think it
was
you're right i think it might have been
sucrose
it's like the ld50s might not even be
you know what i mean like the lethal the
lethality of it is not really
necessarily tied to the
the microbiome in that case if it's not
pollen i don't know just well
so it's still affecting the microbiome
if it's being ingested right so those
fungicides are going in and killing the
floral the gut flora
okay making them
um less immune mm-hmm okay that makes
sense but that's that's the idea with
the microbiome and how the
how they're affecting it
um
so yeah i think with
you're right so
that was
that wasn't done by pollen that was done
by
nectar
but it would still do the same thing
right yeah thank you i've forgotten
about it but but like you said that it
might be a little bit more
um
there's somewhat of a wild card there
right
and maria this is dan rick said if i
could ask a question yeah um
you mentioned why aren't there
requirements to assess real world
exposures after a product is released
for use but there are
uh one thing federal law requires
specialized undergo registration review
every 15 years so after after it's
released they still have to they look at
relevant literature review
to see if they're seeing problems like
this they can also uh epa can require
added data callings
to get more data
and also on did they
dan do they um
how do they incorporate like those
landscape effects
well
that we're talking about like it might
be coming from a neighboring farm or
from
residuals or and stuff like that
how do they well they they can't with
their testing but that's why they look
at the literature and see what's going
on out there
and then they will do
if the need arises they're seeing the
llc being exceeded they go to semi-field
studies and if that's still showing
issues they will go to full field
testing with full colonies to look for
effects on the pesticide
the problem drugs come in where you
can't
it's hard to require a test that looks
for every possible combination of every
possible pesticide that come out that
could be out there because it's
that's infinite no one can do that and
that's why they review the literature
and request further data collins if the
literature is showing issues
i'm going to have been here because we
need to move on to our next speaker but
uh thank you so much maria and maybe if
you'll stay around and
look and chat if any questions do come
up yeah so i'm a graduate student in
entomology as steve said i'm in the
saylor lab and i'm going to talk today
about how
soil management practices might affect
pollinators and
crop disease resistance
so the major manipulations that we make
to the soil and agriculture we know can
affect above ground ecosystem services
and
i'm really interested in how soil
management might dovetail with
managing both pests and pollinators on
farms and so i'm going to talk a little
bit about that generally and then
share some of the research i've done on
this topic
and so we know that the nutrients and
microbes that are provided by soil shape
crop interactions with beneficial and
antagonistic symbionts
which can ultimately affect yield on
farms and so it's important to manage
soil health in a way that promotes yield
while also reducing pest pressures and
mitigating negative effects that might
occur for beneficial organisms
especially pollinators
and there's some evidence that organic
soil management specifically can
condition soil in a way that improves
crop resistance to herbivory and
pathogens which is
interesting
because maybe we can
apply some of those practices that are
used in organic farming to non-organic
systems to at least reduce pesticide and
fungicide use um and some of the ways
that this happen can be by changing soil
nutrient profiles as well as um microbes
in the soil
and the changes to soil properties that
happen from soil conditioning due to
some of these management practices can
change leaves in a way that
is important to pest and pathogen
resistance so
leaf nutrient profiles can change due to
soil and so can some of the chemicals
that plants produce to defend themselves
against pathogens and insect pests
but we also know that the effects of
management practices can take time to
manifest so if we implement a certain
soil management practice in a single
year we might not actually see a
difference in something like pest
pressure or yield um or resistance to
pests i mean um
but
over time we might see a difference with
that management practice and that's
because of this soil conditioning that
can happen
to microbial community or soil structure
or maybe nutrient composition so one of
the focuses of my research when i think
about how soil affects
pest pressures is looking at how
long-term management decisions
over the course of several years can
affect
pest and pathogen resistance
but i'm also interested in how soil
management practices affect pollinators
as i said
there's a lot of discussion about
using cover crops for soil fertility and
how that might
dovetail with providing pollinator
habitat
and so if for example if we let cover
crops flower um we can create an
abundant resource pulse of nectar and
pollen for bees and that's um
like a really great strategy that i'm
not going to talk about today because
i'm more interested in how conditioning
of the soil could affect the quality of
the pollen and nectar that is provided
on farms fees so i'm kind of focusing on
how soil might change the amount or
nutritive components of pollen and
nectar that bees rely on for food
um and so we think that this could
happen because soil
changes leaf tissue as i was just
talking about
by
affecting uh nutrient uptake and uh
chemical production and so like there's
no reason to think that that might not
happen in flowers as well and there is
some evidence that uh nutrients and
microbes in the soil can change uh
macronutrients and pollen and nectar
amino acids and pollen and nectar and
all of these nutritive traits are
important to
um
different stages of the bee life cycle
so diana and maria did a really good job
of explaining
use of food resources across the bee
life cycle so they really need
carbohydrates and fats and proteins
for all of their activities when adults
are foraging they need
abundant uh
nectar and sugar to
fuel their flight and fuel mating and
the pollen is really important for
larval development
and i'm really interested in looking at
how soil affects
pollen and nectar quality in squash for
a couple of reasons um
first because it's a common crop that's
grown that
is affected by
disease so powdery mildew and squash
mosaic virus and striped cucumber beetle
are all significant pressures
but also because it's visited by these
specialist bees that diana and maria
both referenced in their talks um and so
specialist bees have a narrower diet
range than uh what we refer to as
generalist bees that forage on lots of
different species um
and because they only eat pollen and
nectar from one or a handful of
flowering plant species
any effects that
soil might have on the nutrients in
pollen and nectar could have an outsized
effect on these specialist bees um
and that's because they can't really
switch to you know like foraging on
clover or something
and so i'm thinking that soil
environment could affect uh pollen and
nectar through a couple of different
paths so in the same way that soil can
affect leaf quality we might imagine
that nutrients and microbes in the soil
affect nectar and pollen
in a direct way and that that could
scale up to affect
both pollination services and the bees
themselves
um but we also might imagine that by
changing
pests and pathogen pressures that soil
could have indirect effects on bee diet
quality and
bee behavior so we know that when
herbivores chew on leaves or pathogens
attack plants that can constrain their
ability to produce flowers or to produce
high quality sugary nectar or
pollen that bees want to eat
um so i was interested in looking at
these direct and indirect effects that
soil could have on bees so i've teamed
up over the last few years with
some folks from cornell in the cornell
small farms program
who have been running some long-term
experiments manipulating different
fertility inputs um inorganic plots and
um so i collected soil from those plots
and also from some fields that were
under long-term conventional management
on cornell experimental farm sites and i
planted squash in these soils
and then measured herbivory
so insect damage disease
and pollen and nectar nutrients and i
use summer squash as the model system
and i actually used 6spm
that's supposed to be fairly resistant
to powdery mildew which i didn't
actually find to be the case in this
study
but in any case i had these organic and
conventional soils
not going to talk about it today but i
actually used
soils from several different management
practices so within organic we looked at
a few different fertility inputs and
same with conventional um and i'd be
really interested to talk to people
about that uh after just since i can't
go into it today
um
but just jumping to what we found um we
found that soil management had no effect
on cucumber beetle damage so regardless
of whether plants were grown in
conventional or organic soils they got
slammed with cucumber beetle and had uh
equivalent amounts of damage so that
wasn't really what we were expecting to
find
but we did find that plants grown in
soils with organic management history
consistently got less powdery mildew
than plants in conventional soils and we
found that across two years and in the
field as well as in greenhouse
experiments
and then we also saw that plants grown
in soils with organic management history
had more sugar in their nectar and
produced more nectar overall than plants
in conventional soils
and they also made more flowers so on a
per plant basis they're producing more
flowers they're producing more nectar
and more sugar per flower so um the
carbohydrates um
that are present in nectar were
uh on a per plant basis just uh more
abundant in organically grown plants and
um interestingly sometimes the higher
nectar rewards in organic plants were
due to lower powdery mildew infections
so we saw that powdery mildew also
depressed
nectar production so we kind of see a
double effect of organic management
there like it on its own um improves
nectar production but also by reducing
uh disease pressure it can uh promote
nectar production and then bees visited
plants that had um more of these
nectar resources
um but on the other hand we found that
soils in grown in organic soils made
pollen with less protein than plants
grown in conventional soils and it's a
little bit hard to interpret this result
because we don't or actually really
either of these results because we don't
actually know
uh
what effect these changes in uh
nutrients are doing to the bees
um so some of my future work is going to
look at that i've i have pollen and
nectar from plants grown under the
different uh soil
management conditions and i'm gonna feed
it to bees and see how it affects their
uh larval development
and then um from the growers perspective
of course
the big question is how does this affect
yield we did see more visits to squash
plants grown in
uh organic soils as well as in soils
with plants with less powdery mildew
so
the implication of that could be that
yield is higher but it also might not be
so that's something else i'd like to
look at in the future
um
yeah um and i think that's that's all i
wanted to talk about today so i just
wanted to thank everyone in my lab and
at cornell farm services who
helped me with this project as well as
all the funders and i'd be delighted to
take questions or
hear some discussion of this work
thank you so much julie are there any
questions
i don't see any so julie i do want to
thank you and all the speakers for a uh
really fascinating session a little
different than what we've
what we typically
have at the expo and uh really some
things that make us think and lots of
additional research will be coming down
the road i think from this work so again
thank you to
everyone
um
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu